on indonesia's sulawesi island a major
search and rescue effort continues
in the cities of martinezu
the strong shallow quake injured more
than 800 people
and teams are working swiftly to rescue
those trapped under the rubble of
collapsed houses and buildings
we continue to search and rescue from
this morning we have prioritized four
target areas for the operations around
majini at least 000 people are displaced
and seeking shelter in emergency centers
rahmad is one of them his family
survived the disaster
but they are now homeless
my house was flattened by the earthquake
many people from my neighborhood are
dead now
that's why we're here in nearby mumuju
mitra manikara hospital was destroyed
several people were found dead by
rescuers
we will clear the area at mitra manakara
hospital after we confirm there are no
more victims buried
the earthquake set off several
landslides and cut electricity
and relief crews are working to make
sure all survivors have the essentials
we've collected information about what
the people need at evacuation centers
they need medicine
medical supplies to treat those injured
vitamins and other items
the local school was also damaged but
there were no people in the building at
the time
jessica washington al jazeera jakarta